bueno en méxico muchas gracias por este
espacio en méxico la situación de
libertad de prensa de libertad de
expresión es una digamos atraviesa ahora
por una situación muy difícil tan sólo
este año
han asesinado a siete periodistas
la situación del desplazamiento de
periodistas por
agresiones por amenazas también se ha
mantenido hay por lo menos diez
periodistas que han sido desplazados en
los últimos meses a otras ciudades
distintas a igual a guerrero entonces la
situación no es mejor lo único que nos
satisface ahora digamos es este
extraordinario homenaje al periodismo a
través de maría reza y dimite ahora esto
abre también un debate de balbina sobre
cuál es el verdadero aporte del
periodismo a la paz y también la
pregunta de si no existen otro tipo de
actividades con enfoques quizás más
globales y aportes más concretos a la
paz cuál es su postura respecto de esto
bueno la verdad es que el periodismo en
los últimos años el periodismo de
investigación ha hecho grandes aportes
realmente la sociedad ha presenciado
trabajos muy importantes ahora mismo
hemos conocido el trabajo de los pandora
papers es todo un trabajo de muchos más
de 600 periodistas en un tengo tenemos
esta información pero antes teníamos
también los panamá papers que es otro
trabajo de investigación muy importante
entonces creo que el periodismo está
dando grandes lecciones a nivel mundial
de lo que se puede hacer para contribuir
a la democracia era ahora los gobiernos
el reto de responder a este a esta
situación ahora como contracara creo que
también otro tipo de periodismo que
lejos de apoyar a la paz hace lo
contrario
bueno creo que el periodismo el
verdadero periodismo comprometido con
sus lectores
está haciendo el trabajo que le toca
hacer diariamente creo que en el premio
ahora maria riesch a una mujer que ha
luchado durante varios años por un mejor
periodismo y
esto la ha llevado a enfrentar más de 12
por lo menos 12 demandas 8 de ellas
están activas a la fecha creo que este
es un este es un gran mensaje una gran
lección de que el buen periodismo de que
el periodismo de investigación puede
hacer grandes contribuciones